news daily from science mission complex
carbohydrates called proteoglycans
present on the surface of the cell are
required for various cellular functions
but their exact role in various disease
conditions is not clearly understood
scientists used micro RNA 200 family as
decoy to block the synthesis of various
glycosylation reactions and identify
three glycosylation enzymes that are
involved in epithelial to mesenchymal
transitions that is EMT in cancer and
show that these three enzymes are
upregulated in tgf induced EMT next
scientists demonstrate that during
nutrient starvation lipid droplets and
mitochondria disperse in the center of
the cell and relocate on D tyrosine
inherited microtubules they move from
the center to the periphery where their
interaction increases and lipid droplets
efficiently supply fatty acids for
mitochondrial beta oxidation to generate
energy and a protein called ampk
promotes this function for more news
visitors at www science mission calm and
our science mission facebook page thanks
for watching